weitere man lieben zuschauer was mich
umtreibt ist der fall der gerade in
neuruppin verhandelt wird der prozess um
den ehemaligen kz wärter joseph s wegen
beihilfe zum mord in über 3.000 allen
der mann ist 100 und tatsächlich gibt es
hier ein oder andere absurde stimme die
sagt 100-jährigen die kanzlerin bricht
sein ist natürlich völliger käse
gerechtigkeit und schult die haben keine
alte was mich aber viel mehr noch
umtreibt bei diesem fall ist der mann
gestern tatsächlich gänsehaut
bereitet hat als ich den mann auf seinem
rollator da reinkommen sie ist auch sehr
schade fand dass er sein gesicht zu
behalten was ich hätte gerne in seine
augen geblickt ist wenn ich mich
zurückerinnere in den letzten 20 30
jahren wie viele dieser prozesse hatten
wir eigentlich in deutschland wahnsinnig
viele sind das nicht ich kann dann
vielleicht zwei händen haben das darf
nicht sein dass wir in der
nachkriegszeit und in den 60er 70er
jahren da kennen wir mittlerweile die
probleme viel erhalten hat sie es noch
in der justiz und auch beim bnd et
cetera in führenden positionen waren und
das verhindert haben aber warum nicht
die generation danach die nächste
generation danach sich auf die fahnen
schreibt da noch viel genauer
hinzuschauen zu suchen zu holen wo sind
die täter von damals weil es geht nicht
nur um bestrafung der täter nein es geht
auch darum dass die geschichte weiter an
fassbar machen und das geht nirgendwo
besser als in prozessen hoffentlich und
bestmöglich die meiste wahrheit ans
licht kommt möchte dann noch einen
kleinen seiten aspekt hinzufügen es geht
da gar nicht um die um das alter des
angeklagten es geht auch bei dem prozess
gar nicht um die strafe wahrscheinlich
kriegt am ende gar nicht viel weil er
immer zu zweit ist und nicht mehr
richtig haftfähig ist es geht um einen
neu gewonnenen aspekt in der verfolgung
dieser verbrechen das nämlich
überwiegend sie dass männer aber auch
ein paar frauen überwiegend männer die
als wächter die kz bewacht haben und
nicht selbst geschossen haben beim mord
an den gefangenen mitschuldig sind an
diesem massenmord wer ein kz bewacht wer
die häftlinge zur arbeit treibt wer
verhindert dass sie fliehen wer vom
wachturm aus auf häftlinge schießt die
versuchen das lager zu verlassen nimmt
teil an dem gesamten verbrechen was da
stattfindet das ist ein paar jahrzehnte
anders behandelt worden von der justiz
das sind die gar nicht vor gericht
gestellt worden weil die haben ja selbst
nicht geschossen die haben auch selbst
kein da es in die kammern geworfen etc
die waren irgendwie drum herum die hat
man vergessen und jetzt ist eine justiz
am werk die sagt alle die an diesem groß
verbrechen teilgenommen habe und sei es
auch durch arbeit auf dem wachturm
sind an dem verbrechen beteiligt und mit
schuld und diese diese prozesse finden
jetzt eigentlich nur deshalb statt um
diese these juristisch zu untermauern da
gibt es ein paar verfahren aber noch
nicht viele die sind auch noch nicht bis
zur letzten instanz durchgefochten und
deshalb braucht man mehrere verfahren um
diese anklage abzusichern und zu sagen
so sehen wir das jetzt die waren auch
beteiligt und sind million schuldig
bei dem thema interessiert mich eure
meinung die direkt fragen möchte haltet
ihr es nicht für sinnvoll dass solche
prozesse im live stream live übertragen
werden ich hatte mir hat neben das thema
schule ich glaube das eine ist ein buch
aufgeschlagen wo schwarz weiß bilder
drin sind und danach kolorierte in weiß
rot und schwarz in den meisten farben
dann ja leider ist es nicht sinnvoll
eine schulklasse hinzusetzen zwangs zu
verhaften in dem fall und zu sagen ihr
schaut jetzt den ganzen tag diesem
prozess die aussagen sind
deutschlandweit nachdem deutscher leider
nicht zuletzt müssen wir da nicht
einfach auch mal ran könnte man machen
ist ist oft diskutiert worden auch unter
diesem aspekt und es gibt gab immer gute
argumente zu sagen ist nicht so schlecht
ist nämlich ein weil man in den usa
sieht dass ein spektakel daraus gemacht
wird also auch die anwälte staatsanwälte
wie verteidiger machen leicht ein
spektakel daraus wenn man sich den
prozess gegen oj simpson noch einmal in
erinnerung rufen das ist ein relativ
normaler mordprozess nicht zu
vergleichen mit sowas aber
da sieht man was ist das für ein theater
wird also in den usa sind diese
öffentlich übertragenen prozesse wie
eine theaterbühne also das hat man in
israel oft gemacht und auch live gezeigt
und das war kein theater sondern eine
auseinandersetzung mit der geschichte
und teilweise auch mit der traum hat die
diese menschen vor allem in israel
erlebt haben das war sehr wichtig auch
da zu sein und diesen morde auch in den
augen man denn in israel nur diese
prozesse übertragen oder alle mann hat
nun diese putzen
bei aller liebe also das eine ist
mordprozess von einem prominenten
popstar und das andere ist ein
verbrechen in der tat ja menschlicher
grund
manche international ballet 30 also ich
glaube dass du den ausstand glaube dass
13 14 jährige möglicherweise schon in
der lage sind um zum prozess anzuordnen
dann ist von mir aus der abiturjahrgang
wir haben nur fakt ist nirgendwo glaube
ich ist geschichte so anfassbar wie in
so ein prozess wo leute aussagen bücher
filme dokumentationen auf ihr einen ring
für dem prinzip ja aber
wenn du mal durch eine kz-gedenkstätte
durch gehst ja noch existieren und
suchst dir die baracken an durch die
schulklassen durchgeführt worden sind
und liest was sie da mit dem
kugelschreiber die balken kanada
dramatisch und was sie da rein
geschnitzt haben ja also bewegung aber
das ist eben nur die perspektive der
opfer
was mich interessieren würde ist die
perspektive der täter auch tatsächlich
mal zuhören nicht um den eine bühne zu
bieten sondern um zu sehen ob es
tatsächlich eine auseinandersetzung mit
der eigenen schuld gegeben und die sehe
ich nicht die kann die fühle ich auf
ganz auf den ovarien irgendwie sache
höre dann lege ich auch okay
das ist eigentlich total in deutschland
besteht und wenn man sich dann irgendwie
anguckt wer und warum wurden diese
ganzen leute nicht mitverantwortlich
gemacht
wenn man diese ganzen leute nicht und
ich schließe mich mit ein weil ich bin
auch deutsche ich trage auch eine
verantwortung und die verantwortung
besteht darin dass so etwas nicht noch
einmal passiert wenn man diese leute
damals in die verantwortung gezogen
hätte dann hätte es kein deutschland
hält es niemanden mehr gegeben der
deutschland mit aufbaut es gab ganz
viele die nichts gemacht habe ich würde
ein bisschen tiefer gehen ich gebe euch
alle recht aber wir haben jetzt gerade
eine phase wo viele leute die das erlebt
haben nicht mehr am leben sind und wir
haben viele jugendliche die sagen das
hat mit mir nichts zu tun da habe ich
keine emotionale bindung dazu und ich
glaube solche prozesse sind wichtig um
die geschichte wieder
gegenwärtig zu machen um einfach auch
die jugend dazu zu bewegen nicht an die
vergangenheit zu denken sondern wie
verhindert man in der zukunft dass so
was passiert wir haben ja in dem land in
den letzten wochen auch antisemitische
attacken erlebt das ist ein zustand den
wir nicht akzeptieren sollen und sind
wir ein kz
gedenkstätte denken dann ist der
programme die da laufen für die schüler
und schülerinnen unattraktiv dass
erreicht die leute nicht wir arbeiten
auch mal nicht länger sogar und bevor
man dann hingeht muss man sie
vorbereiten man muss auch über ihre
eigene biografie spricht man muss sie
gewinnen und dann so ein besuch machen
und dann kann man das kann kann das
helfen ich glaube dass die prozesse
nicht geeignet sind im prinzip um
jugendliche damit so vertraut zu machen
dass sie es auch empfinden also nicht
nur hören und sehen was da angeklagte
sagen oder der staatsanwalt vor trägt
sondern dass sie dafür was empfinden
dass sie nachvollziehen können was da
passiert ja aber was ich mich etwas an
geht auch anders das hat in deutschland
hat das mit empfinden erst begonnen als
es die holocaust filme gab ja das waren
zum teil hollywood schinken die nicht
sonderlich gut waren war das leder & co
oder via schiller süßes ist ein anderer
fall wikipedia ist er habe damals eine
holocaust serie die war auch in ordnung
sie hat viele deutsche aufgeweckt weil
sie dann mit menschen mit gelitten haben
ich habe jetzt gelesen dass bei der
gedenkstätte den barmenia in in der
ukraine wo glaube ich 37.000 juden
innerhalb von wenigen tagen erschossen
worden sind in einer schlucht da gab es
jetzt eine erinnerungsfeier machte
bundespräsident da war da wird an einem
anderen eingedenk konzept gearbeitet
sehr umstritten aber interessant da
sollen nämlich
besuchern ermöglicht werden den
massenmord aus der perspektive der täter
zu sehen durch bewegte bilder wie hat
das für die damals ausgesehen wenn die
auf juden geschossen haben die da vor
ihnen lagen und wiederum auf der von aus
einer anderen perspektive aus der sicht
der opfer also du siehst den massenmord
aus zwei perspektiven da kannst du dir
vielleicht weiß man nicht vielleicht ein
bisschen er plausibel machen
wie diese männer die damals tagelang nur
geschossen haben unbewaffnete menschen
frauen und kinder vor allen dingen was
die empfunden haben die waren ja häufig
früher in deutschland polizisten gewesen
es waren ja polizei bataillone die also
hier eingesetzt worden sind um mord und
totschlag aufzuklären oder zu verhindern
und dort selbst zu mördern und
totschlägern geworden sind das zu
begreifen gelingt vielleicht durch sowas
vielleicht ich bin haben heute andere
teschner und mussten andere wege in
sachen ich weiß nicht ob das klappt oder
nicht da wären also eigenen eines
prozesses ja einen möglichen absage eine
möglichkeit dass gerade gesagt aus der
sicht des der täter auch mal zu schauen
so ein prozess wenn das total richtig
wenn ich das aber heute richtig
nachgelesen habe wollte sich heute der
josefs der 100 jährige angeklagte äußern
und was ist passiert sein verteidiger
tatsächlich um das mikro abgetreten das
ist so unglaublich pervers dann müsste
man eigentlich schon fast wieder das
strafgesetz ordnung und alles alles
richtig aber da als sie das gelesen habe
ist es mir wirklich kalt den rücken
runtergelaufen dass der verteidiger und
es geht denn du hast das richtige ist
geht der garten ende gar nicht mehr um
die strafe es geht um die aufklärung und
die sicht war so wenn der verteidiger
das mikrofon das seines mandanten
abgehakt hat gerade eine reinere also
lagern kann ich habe gar nicht
geschossen ich stand nur auf dem
wachturm und da bin ich hingestellt
worden das darf nicht mehr möglich sein
denn ohne die ging es nicht das ist ein
sehr geschlossen norbert film hat mal
gesagt und das hat er in mein
riesenärger eingetragen ohne die
wehrmacht die die front gehalten hätte
hätte dahinter nicht vernichtet werden
können und das war natürlich ein angriff
auf die wehrmacht der war damals
atemberaubend und sie haben ihn fast den
kopf abgeschlagen dafür aber natürlich
hat er recht wenn die front nicht
gehalten hätte werden die kz früher
befreit worden und es werden weniger
menschen umgebracht worden keine frage
[Musik]